cédric arvieu infectiologues au chu de
rennes cédric arvier bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
en ile de france tous les indicateurs
sont au rouge avec des taux d'incidence
parmi les plus élevés du pays
le gouvernement qui n'a toujours pas à
confiner la région quel regard portez
vous sur la situation à paris notamment
et sa région ou qui feront dire qu'avec
le père jean simard on n'a plus d'autre
on est donc voilà une saturation du thé
qui s'aggrave donc c'est vrai que la
région en région parisienne est
inquiétant des animations être alarmiste
de saclay transfert de ne pas commencer
au total six patients pour être
transféré tout ce week-end trois encore
aujourd'hui évacuer des malades pour
faire baisser la pression hospitalière
c'est une bonne méthode selon vous oui
disons clouds c'est donc on n'a pas
énormément choix on est dans une
situation où effectivement dans l'ouest
de la france la tension au niveau des
services de réanimation est beaucoup
moins importante donc donc c'est une
question de solidarité entre régions en
pratique donc c'est des transferts qui
sont complexes qui comptent sont
complexes pour les patients qui sont
complexes pour les équipes
mais voilà on l'a démontré avec la avec
la première vague c des transferts qui
fonctionne quand même assez bien qui
permettent de donner des bonnes
situations prise en charge des patients
qui seraient dans beaucoup de situations
beaucoup plus difficile s'il restait
dans l'eure dans leurs zones d'origine
c'est particulièrement difficile pour
les familles aussi d'éloigner les
personnes
c'est des choses qu'on prend en compte
mais voilà c'est une solution
on aimerait ne pas y recourir mais c'est
une solution qui est quand même une
bonne solution pour les patients
et une solution plus radicale c'est à
dire un confinement strict on parle
beaucoup d'un confinement strict pendant
une semaine en tout cas c'est ce que
l'on peut voilà lire entre les lignes
pour l'instant pour paris et sa région
ce serait la méthode idéale finalement
pour éviter que les hôpitaux soient sous
pression on parle de plus de 4100
malades qui sont en réanimation
actuellement ses traits et des décisions
qui sont extrêmement difficiles à
prendre
c'est un peu facile de dire voilà c'est
pas une bonne décision de confiner une
partie de la région paca le week-end et
pas confiné par icc des décisions qui
sont qui sont d'une complexité extrême
en termes de quel impact on va voir si
l'épidémie quel impact on va avoir sur
les sur les hospitalisations réanimation
quel impact peut avoir sur la population
générale en termes de orco vide on va
dire donc ces décisions qui sont très
difficiles donc voilà il ya les équipes
qui réfléchissent à ça c'est moi en tant
qu'un fake sur l'eau que j'ai pas d'avis
spécifiquement sur la question de savoir
est ce qu'il faut confirmer ou pas ce
qu'on voit c'est que à ce qu'on voit
quand même aujourd'hui c'est que alors
que les mesures de couvre-feu ont été
prises il ya un certain temps maintenant
elles suffisent pas à aplatir la courbe
d admission en réanimation région
parisienne et donc c'est ça qui fait
dire il faut faire quelque chose de plus
voilà mais quoi exactement voilà c'est
des décisions politiques qui doivent
être prises ensuite
alors on parle beaucoup du variant
anglais qui est beaucoup plus contagieux
que les autres 64% plus mortel que la
souche initial indus coronavirus on a vu
aussi l'apparition
du variant sud-africain brésilien est ce
qu'on doit s'attendre éventuellement à
d'autres mutations du virus
ah oui c'est l'apparition des variants
c'est quelque chose à laquelle on
s'avoue là c'est quelque chose de
complètement attendu le da cau vie des
virus de la colline des pins vie
rustique ligne varie énormément par
rapport à ce que je connais d'autres
virus mais voilà un satan il va y avoir
d'autres mutations
ce qui est important c'est de bien
surveiller de vérifier qu'on a on se
retrouve face à des mules tant qu'ils ne
seraient plus difficiles à diagnostiquer
qui seraient éventuellement plus grave
la gravité augmenté du variant angles et
elle et elle est quand même difficile à
interpréter donc voilà au manque encore
un petit peu de recul on a l'impression
que c'est plus grave mais les données
sont quand même un petit peu
contradictoire ce qu'on espère quand
même c'est que on a quand même des
vaccins qui sont efficaces sur la
plupart des variants des vaccins à venir
qui sont aussi efficaces sur le vario un
sud africain
voilà il ya il ya une la politique de
mise en place des vaccins est vraiment
complexe arrivée on a n'a vous dire
voilà on aimerait en faire vacciner plus
de noms mais on a depuis signé
énormément de monde ont très peu de
temps il faut arriver petit à petit à
mettre en place cette vaccination de
façon plus large avec eux avec plus de
vaccins mais aussi de bien étudier les
données qui nous ont transmises en
termes de vaccins l'instant on a quatre
vaccins lesquels les données ont pu être
examinés l'europe y en aura d'autres
après mais voilà c'est quelque chose qui
se fait par petites étapes
c'est la seule arme efficace aujourd'hui
elle
les vaccins contre locaux vides 19 on
parle plus beaucoup de traitements
alors on a des traitements qui sont oui
on parle beaucoup de la vaccination
parce que parce que voilà s'est hérissé
le sujet le du mouvement et puis c'est
le sujet probablement le plus important
mais on a des traitements notamment ce
qu'on appelle des anticorps monoclonaux
on en a un premier pour lesquelles on a
une autorisation temporaire
d'utilisation mais qui est d'une
efficacité relativement modérée mais on
a des cocktaïls de ce qu'on appelle de
d'anticorps monoclonaux qui arrivent sur
le marché et qui sont intéressants pour
des personnes qui sont à risque de faire
des formes graves
on espère qu'on aura moins en moins
parce que ces personnes là auront été
identifiés vaccinés
il peut y avoir des personnes qui
débutent une co vide et dont on sait
qu'ils sont à risque de faire des
complications et ces personnes là elles
relèveront de ses nouveaux traitements
qui seront probablement mises en oeuvre
d'ici là d'ici là du moins merci
beaucoup
cédric à arvieu d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
infectiologues au chu de rennes